كأنني عانيت من ألم شديد
على رقبتي لسنوات عديدة مما جعلني أشعر بالكثير من الصداع
13 صورة بالرنين المغناطيسي حيث قالوا إنه لا يوجد
شيء خاطئ إلا أنك كنت تعاني من هذا
الموقف السيئ حقًا لسنوات عديدة
وربما قد ترغب في رؤيته
يحاول بعض المعالجين الفيزيائيين بلطف اللجوء إلى
العلاج اليدوي الصحيح الذي يستخدمه
المعالجون الفيزيائيون لتقييم وعلاج الألم ، ونقص
المرونة في الحركة إذا كنا ننظر
إلى ما يسبب ألم شخص ما ، فنحن نفعل
ذلك من خلال أيدينا سيشعر
بالقيود المفروضة على الأنسجة و
يتم إجراء اختبار المفاصل لمعرفة أن
العلاج اليدوي مناسب لذلك المريض ،
وسوف نستخدم تقنيات مختلفة للأنسجة الرخوة
لتحسين الانزلاق والحركة
في المفاصل عندما دخلت Fe لاحظت أن
لديها وضعية رأس Ford والتي يستخدمها الكثير
منا مع هذه أجهزة الكمبيوتر  في هذه الأيام ،
إذا لم تتحرك هنا ، فسوف
تأخذ الركود هنا ،
فلديها عضلات صدرية ضيقة جدًا ، لذا
لم يكن لديها القدرة على الجلوس بشكل مستقيم ، وكان
برنامج التمرين الخاص بها يتألف من
بدأ شد عضلات الصدر
لحملها على فتح وضعيتها في
التحسن وهذا وضع ضغطًا أقل على تلك
المنطقة الوسطى من عنق الرحم بعد حوالي شهر
توقفت عن الشعور بالألم يمكنني
إعادة الكتفين بدلاً من الانحناء فقط
أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة